good morning Hank it's Tuesday November
12 2013 11 12 13 I learned an
interesting fact today which is that
sugar does not make children hyperactive
now I know what you're saying Hank yes
it does because you remember being a kid
and drinking a coke and then you and I
would like run around in circles for
hours and hours and hours hold on active
button up this button what are we
shooting here some kind of swimsuit
catalog but it doesn't hang sugar does
not cause hyperactivity and there are
more studies attesting to this then
there are studies proving that like most
drugs humans take are safe you know on
second thought I think I need to come
down a button a girl okay Henry anyway
if you don't believe me just watch this
healthcare triage video by dr. Aaron
Carroll dr. Carroll hops on a blog
called incidental economist that I stole
from a lot in my video about healthcare
costs and then it turns out that he
lives in Indianapolis so we met and now
we are producing a show that he's making
about healthcare that adds like nuance
and complexity to the conversation you
know all the things that traditional
healthcare reporting is lacking so if
you want understand like drug trials and
insurance and why sugar highs are not
actually caused by sugar you should
check out healthcare triage you can
click here or else there's also a link
in the doobly-doo anyway dr. Garrow also
writes books which I have read two of in
the last 24 hours because they are
highly addictive and also because they
have revealed that my entire life is a
lie
like for instance teething does not
cause babies to have fevers married
people have more sex than single people
of the same age and also report that the
sex they have is better using a sponge
to clean your kitchen counter will
likely make your kitchen counter dirtier
than it was before because the average
sponge contains more pathogens than like
the average toilet seat lifting heavy
boxes does not cause hernias it can
reveal hernias but it doesn't cause them
Americans are not more likely to commit
suicide around Christmas if you stop
exercising your muscles do not turn into
fat which is good news from my emerging
guns also as you gain weight the number
of fat cells in your body doesn't
increase it's just that the size of them
increases sit-ups do not flatten your
stomach and in great news for me you are
not more likely to get an infection from
being on an airplane than from being in
any other public space like an office
building or a bus or whatever but you
are more likely to acquire a disease in
any of those places than you are if you
just like stay in your house by yourself
so thank you internet also Hank I
learned that in rare instances vomiting
hard and frequently can cause your eyes
to pop out of your head so that's a good
thing for a hypochondriac like myself to
know because it ensures that for the
rest of my
if I will be puking with my eyes closed
okay Henry so daddy cannot eat worm
pizza your first suggestion for the
gross thing I should eat because it
turns out eating worms can be really bad
for you it can be kind of poisonous well
because they have bacteria on them those
little microbes you know yeah so we
can't eat them
so what gross thing should I eat from my
punishment slobber carrots what are
those you're gonna drool on slobber
carrots and then I have to eat it Henry
wasn't there something else that you
wanted me to eat really gross barbeque
what does that mean we're gonna make it
are we gonna make it gross together so
we're gonna have slobber carrots with
Henry drool and really gross barbeque
with Henry drool what how about wooden
shoes a wooden shoe no I mean I don't
think I can eat I might be able eat a
little part of a wooden shoe no no what
is you know what should I eat then no
lights the visible sign of the invisible
light hmm I don't see how I can eat
light itself because it's more of an
idea than it is a thing in my brain your
mouth that's a good point
that would hurt I just had to eat
something to taste gross ah hats
yeah all right so we're gonna have
slobber carrots with drool really gross
barbecue with drool and hats what all
right thanks to the punishment Hank I'll
see you on Friday